join my day Joe Rogan podcast one night
okay first of all congratulations on
your belt or fight man you looked
outstanding thank you thanks a lot like
clicking Mads really coming together
yeah finally the muscle memory is back
and I'm at a new camp that's great for
my style training with Raphael Lovato
junior may be the best American grappler
for BJJ was accomplished maybe he's
fantastic
oh you're right so you in Oklahoma where
he's at yeah Oklahoma just moved there
and it's a move data train yeah
move there to Train and interesting
train alongside him and that's also
where water force headquartered at Oh Oh
Houma City how [ __ ] convenient
absolutely so now have the best of both
worlds my two passions right there
that's amazing that's amazing
he's really good bad yeah Rafael Lovato
has that pressure style to the Solow
Ribeiro yeah smashing style very fun to
watch that guy the only guy I've ever
felt claustrophobic underneath was how
he's just I can't I can't explain you
just can't I get away that smash pass at
pressure pea he just melts into you and
there's no escape it's like he's melting
and he's like glue yeah Salo Shan ji the
whole that whole family of that style of
jujitsu is so powerful man yeah I've
gotten to meet both of them now train
with solo and then Shan ji was there in
the corner so it's pretty awesome for a
Bellator fight and I was I was kind of
bummed out Raphael Lovato's last fight
so he stopped him with strikes yeah like
god damn it yeah kicked him in the head
yeah seconds yeah it's crazy I mean it's
great to see him succeed and do well but
I wanted to see a jiu-jitsu
oh yeah absolutely I think people will
but he's been he's an animal honestly
he's one of those guys that is so
well-rounded and you think he's just
one-dimensional because of everything
he's done introduced ooh but he grew up
kickboxing Oh didn't really oh yes dad's
been a lifelong martial artist
senior he's an incredible guy and he's
been taking Rafael all around the world
since he was a little boy having them
trained mixed martial arts not just Jiu
Jitsu is a life and he's fighting
Bellator as well right yeah that was his
first fight so we fought back-to-back he
fought right before me I fought right
after him
oh that's nice yeah Alatorre is making
some moves man you know they're doing
Mitrione versus phaidor and they're
going to lorenz larkin just sign with
them
Rory MacDonald signed with them
that's a stable now they have a
legitimate a like specially their
170-pound division is Superleggera daily
and be Lima Lima Korsakov yeah that's a
serious division man and now phaidor
very interesting what did you think
about the fate or Mitrione thing with it
how to pull out like MIT your own how to
pull out because of his kidney stone and
yeah and they're going to schedule the
Ganic apparently magenta has clears and
square gardens yeah jim's paper would
write a review first one for Bellator
review stuff man yeah i forget people to
buy something that would get in for free
right and but i think i think this card
there they're stacking it pretty heavily
Chael Sonnen versus vandal yeah that
would shy that's where raphael has been
going down into a tree outside like your
tea party like Xillia down there and was
sparring with Wanderlei before his fight
farmer vandala is a fight apparently
yeah apparently of fighting this he sent
me a meme of something like let's train
easy um and then releasing like yeah
train easy but it's that picture of him
in pride or something or maybe train
where he's jumping in the air and he's
just coming down with the big hammer
fist and gonna land on you with his feet
yeah like that's a light day he's kind
of known for that being a barbarian 24/7
yeah but that's why it was so fun to
watch and i think what you said and just
asked about what did I think between
fader and Matt Mitrione when they had
pull out I mean I flashback right away -
do you remember whenever Stefan Struve
had to pull out of his fight with
Mitrione backstage and yeah yeah they
were
he's like black and out or something
right yeah there's Pat it out a couple
times and he's having a heart problem as
well but
Mitrione was back there all gloved up
already taped up had his gloves on was
hitting mitts and then there's some of
the behind-the-scenes cameras that
caught a moment where I really was Dana
coming back they're telling the fight
was cancelled and Mitrione just was you
know cussing up a storm no way not at
all no but then all sudden you saw it
shift where el sudden he was worried
about Stefan
and he walked down there went backstage
or to his locker room it man he just
hugged him it's definitely sobbing and
Matt Mitrione was just like you know hey
it's alright bro
I know if you could fight you would have
and all that other stuff and so I guess
he had passed at least one or two kidney
stones
to fight week maybe
a couple days before weigh-ins and then
the day of the fight they just started
coming back out I think you had
something like 15 or 25 so man I I know
all the ladies out there you you're a
lot tougher than us giving birth but I
hear this is the equivalent you know for
the men inside out any stone I doubt it
yeah let's be like more like passing a
marble through the check hole
you know maybe even a golf ball it seems
like it's not even close yeah it
probably hurts yes it sucks yeah it does
for that 15 or 20 of them something like
that actually brutal and so just wanted
to
[Applause]
[Music]